hey guys I'm back in Exeter for a few
days I'm actually in the chapel where I
used to sing right now because I have
been doing some recording you can
actually see the microphones here behind
me for the chapel choir and this
actually is a really appropriate place
between sort of recording sessions to
talk about homo dare I realized that I
have promised this book review for so so
long and I actually finished the book
probably a month ago but I've just been
so busy I haven't had a chance to film
this because of both lots of projects
like this those of you who follow my
Goodreads link down there in the
description will already have heard a
review from me but I wanted to talk a
little bit more in this video and just
add a bit more detail to my thoughts on
the book because actually the further
out from having read it they've changed
a bit so on a descriptive level homo
Deus is the book following sapiens by
Eva Harare so the first book was an
absolute smash here I absolutely loved
it and it's kind of impossible to not
compare this book to sapiens for a
couple of reasons because obviously the
same author kind of similar subject but
the way in which the subject matter is
presented in this book is very similar
to sapiens which if you haven't read
it's very kind of broad brushstrokes in
history it's a towering
top-down view of human history and
looking at things like for example the
Agricultural Revolution and why it
happened and its impact on humans from
when it first occurred to the present
day a lot of the same kind of techniques
are used in homo Deus and that's both a
good and a bad thing it's a good thing
when the book talks about similar
subject matter to sapiens because the
book is divided into three and the first
two sections so this much of the book
really is kind of an extension of
sapiens it's talking about history and
bringing up to the present day and this
two thirds of the book is really solid
stuff it's basically the same as sapiens
and to give you very briefly what it
talks about it introduces this idea of
objective subjective ideas but then also
into subjective ideas such as for
example religion and that's pretty
similar if you've read sapiens it will
sound quite familiar and really the book
goes on to say that the defining
religion of the modern period isn't an
Abrahamic religion or Islam or anything
like that
it's humanist humanism is this idea that
each human is sacred if you like and
that the ultimate authority comes from
within from the individual and
idea is kind of everywhere in the modern
world it's so fundamental to us that we
don't question it as a belief we just
hold it to be well self-evident to use
the words of the US Constitution and
this approach to viewing humanism as a
religion and then how it kind of
manifests itself in different economic
systems so it talks about communism for
example versus fascism it's super
interesting and I feel like it's
probably not terribly controversial
within an academia the stuff that he
puts in this book is probably popular
science writing but you know it's
broadly their academics I'm gonna have a
problem with the cracks start to appear
in the book probably probably about here
actually as soon as that it goes into
the final section because when the
author starts talking about where these
religions are going to move into the
future cracks just start to appear in
how easily he dismisses for example the
presence of modern-day religions like
Islam and Christianity and just saying
well they don't have anything to offer
us let's just ignore them and I remember
reading this on the tube and being like
it feels a bit too out of hand for the
way that billions of people live their
lives by that point in the book you're
kind of buoyed by the comparisons the
sapiens and how similar it is so you
just think well you know it's just a bit
of a fastening a bit odd but let's carry
on and then basically you expect the
final part of this book to be the same
kind of analysis but looking at the
future looking at how technology is
going to change human society in the
future and it kind of does that it just
about get started and then the book ends
it ends actually quite abruptly it's not
an appeal affliction but it kind of yet
just stops mid train of thought as if he
just kind of ran out of time writing it
to be a bit more specific the book talks
about how new technology and
specifically machine learning which is
sort of the big thing that is postulated
in this book as reshaping how humans
interact with each other how that's
going to change society and it could be
in the form of a data religion or it
could be in the form of a kind of caste
based system where the wealthy become
augmented and becomes so far beyond the
everyday Jo like you and me Elon if
you're watching this that that doesn't
apply to you also hi and I feel like
that was a really interesting point to
start on and I just wish
I wish that you've developed it because
it basically says this might happen and
then doesn't really talk about how that
would change society which is why I
wanted to read this bloody book in the
first place I wanted to know how society
will change if there is a cast cast
wherever you come from of humans who are
superhuman who are augmented with
implants with technology there's just
not available so that there's a vast
majority of people because another
oversight of this book is he kind of
assumes that everybody is going to want
to do this and want to have machinery
put in their bodies and be augmented
with all this kind of stuff
realistically it is only going to be
accessible to the very very rich and yes
I know there are people gonna be
commenting saying yeah to begin with
that'll be true but it's like the cost
of these procedures and then the
societal impacts on certain people
getting them not wanting everybody to
get them will prevent it in my opinion
this is around conjecturing will prevent
widespread adoption of the technology
and so you will get stratification
that's a super interesting concept that
I just wish he developed a bit more it
kind of felt a little bit like an
undergraduate essay in that light you
read it and it's like oh that's a really
interesting point come you know follow
through oh you know just going to hit me
with the conclusion because the
frustrating thing is this book makes
some very interesting predictions it
talks about for example I remember
reading this on the tube again and there
was a section talking about how with the
advent of machine learning it will be
possible to not just or even very common
to own a car you will share a car and
you know it will drive to you pick you
up take you want where you want to go
and then it'll go over to the next
person who has a timeshare in it at that
moment I looked up and there was an
advert for a car sharing service like on
the tube because this book was written
in 2015 and since it was written that's
come to pass he also talks about
increasing disillusionment with politics
and the rise of politicians in name
drops brexit a new name drops Donald
Trump before he was elected and points
out that yeah there's probably going to
be populist candidates who are appealing
you were using similar techniques to
extreme governments in the past extreme
right-wing governments and will be
successful and we have seen this rising
tide of populism that has taken place
since this book was written so he Klee
has some ideas and has some foresight
into how society and technology are
going to interact because the rise of
the populism is um I don't really want
to get into this in a heated video
because I don't want this comment
section to be worse than my climate
change once suffice to say that he has
made some short-term predictions in this
book which have already come to pass and
so it's frustrating to not see the same
broad brushstroke approach to history
applied to our near future and saying
well this is actually where I think this
technology is going to lead beyond the
next couple of years obviously
everything is hard to predict and
especially the future but given his
approach I would have just loved to have
seen him talk about it a bit more and
frankly the book was a bit of a slog to
get into yes I was a big fan of sapiens
and so I liked his approach in the first
two sections but just when you think
it's gonna get interesting as I said
cracks start to appear and then the book
just kind of ends to be honest if you're
interested in the way that machine
learning is likely to impact human
society in the future I wouldn't read
this I would read the master algorithm
by Pedro Dominguez because that goes
into much more detail and gives you a
technical grounding in the subject but
it goes into much more detail in some
sort of ideas some some possible routes
that machine learning and society could
interact and I found that much more
compelling a much better fall through
than the end of this book there'll be a
link to that actually links to this in
the description below if you want to
check out the books on Amazon that's
just my opinion though if you have read
this book and I did stay a very long
time ago that we would read this as a
channel and I do apologize for taking so
long let me know in the comments I
genuinely read every comment on these
book videos so do leave a little review
and to say if you agree with me or not
do you think this is kind of a
unfortunately inferior sequel to sapiens
or did you love this let me know as I
said before there'll be a link down
there in the description to my Goodreads
and to the Amazon pages before the books
and I will be back in not too long
hopefully with another book video where
I'm rereading my favorite book series of
all time because the 15th book in it has
just been released and I plan on
reviewing the entire series so you've
got that to look forward to oh and an
interview with a very special book fan
which again won't be too long before you
see that I'm really excited to edit that
thank you very much for watching do
leave your thoughts on hemo days in the
com
and I'll see you next time Jonah come in
here for the end of the video I was
filming this between recording sessions
and the chapel quiets just come back
thanks for watching I'll see you in the
next one
[Music]